...Hello. Guess what? It's pastry week.
Are you excited for pastry week, Noel?
...I am. Prue's made us all these
fabulous pastries
to get us in the mood.
Try one of these. They're
delish delosh.... I certainly will.
...PASTRY WHINES
...Don't eat me. I'm nice.
...Did you hear something? No.... Oh!
...PASTRY SPEAKS... Murderer.
...Welcome... to
The Great British Bake Off.
Last time...... Ready, steady...
.....the bakers faced chocolate week...
...They're a bit raw.
.....and collectively ballsed up the
basics.
...This looks like they've been
dropped.... Yeah.
...They fought back with stunning
celebration cakes...
...The overall appearance, I think, is
spectacular.
.....but Lottie still found herself in
the firing line.
...It's overbaked.... Although in the end
it was Sura..... You have raw dough.
.....who bit the bullet.
Now, midway through the
competition...
...Halfway to paradise.
.....the bakers face the perils of
pastry week.
...It's bonkers.
...Taking on some of the most intricate
challenges...
...There's so many steps in this.
.....ever set.... This is definitely the
hardest so far.
...Making architecture edible,
but the wrong kind of flaky...
...Just really baffled.
...This is a joke...can see the best
of plans...
...This is what this entire bake hinges
on.
...This is horrendous.
.....come crashing down.
...It's pastry week!
This is the week that I wanted to get to
because I know that I can make pastry.
You know, lots of us mums can make
pastry.
...I can finally say that I am looking
forward to pastry week.
It is my week!
...Halfway has suddenly crept up on us,
hasn't it?
It feels bizarre that we're already
at this point, yeah.
We're so far through, um, exciting
though.
...I do like making pastry, but I
have to say this is definitely
one of the weeks where a lot could
go wrong.
Nobody wants a soggy bottom.
Got a crisp bottom.
...I feel apprehensive, actually, about
pastry.
The judges are saying they want to
see a bit more refinement from me.
So, I want to show them that I can
do elegant. Yeah.
...Good morning, bakers. Welcome back
to the tent
for pastry week.
And it's time for your
Signature Challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue would like you
each to make your version
of the Cornish national dish -
the pasty.
...You need to make eight identical
pasties.
You can use any pastry or filling
you choose,
but feel free to personalise them
with a decorative finish.
...They need to be at least 15cm long,
but they can be any shape you like.
Noel, what shape would yours be?
...Mine would be in the shape of Paul
Hollywood's powerful buttocks.
Mmm, delish delosh.
You have two hours... On your marks..
...Get set... bake!
...Hello, hello, pasties.
...Puff pastry will make a good pasty.
...Nice and buttery.
...Packed with filling.
...Why did they have to say it's the
Cornish national dish?
Just to give me more pressure?
...It's pastry week. Most of our
challenges are pure baking
challenges.
This time, the bakers have to be
good cooks too
because what's going inside the
pasty takes real cooking.
...The trick is choosing your pastry
and your filling wisely.
You don't want it to be too dry.
As you bite into the pasty, the buttery layer
from the shell must be nice and thin, crisp y.
And then inside, as you hit that filling, you
want a bit of moisture in there as well.
...It doesn't have to be
a Cornish pasty shape,
it can be any shape they like,
but we want crimping.
...Halfway through now, and I expect the
bakers really to start pushing themselves
and coming up with some ingenious
ways to really impress the judges.
...I want to eat the best
pasties I've ever had.
...Hello, Laura... Morning... Hello,
Laura...Making a mess again, I see... Yep.
...Tell us about your pasty.
...So, I'm going quite traditional.
I'm doing a cheese and onion pasty.
...Paul just said to me, not 30 seconds ago, that he
likes a cheese and onion pasty.... Oh, reall ...y?
...Laura's pimping her
traditional cheese and onion filling
with leeks,
cream and fresh thyme,
and she's aiming to impress
with her choice of pastry too.
...I'm doing a cheats puff pastry learnt from a book
from a very famous baker called Paul Hol ...lywood.
I think you'll do well on this
challenge.... You reckon?
...Well, if it all falls to bits,
it's his fault, isn't it? Yeah.
...I'm not taking the blame. Good luck,
Laura.
...Thank you,
thanks.... Thank you.
...I just can't mess it up.
...But she's not the only baker
taking a risk making rough puff.
...Flaky pastry. It doesn't
matter how you get there, right?
...Lottie, Peter and Linda are all using
it to reimagine the traditional pasty.
...You're meant to see
streaks of butter in your pastry.
...I'm doing an envelope fold. An
envelope fold, letter fold. I don't know.
...Whilst rivals Marc, Mark,
and Dave are making a sturdy short crust.
...You could overwork it.
You don't want it to turn tough.
...But Hermine is creating a
pastry that is entirely her own.
...It's not quite a puff pastry,
but it's not a short pastry either.
I kind of wanted
best of both worlds.
...Hermine's hybrid
pastry will be packed with a
tangy Moroccan
spiced lamb tagine
and chickpea filling.
...I think it sounds absolutely delicious.
As long as the pastry doesn't fall to bits.
...Thank you.
...How much chilli have I
got? I haven't got too much.
...Planning to pack a punch
with his pasties is Mark.
...So, I am doing aloo gobi and paneer pasties, which
will be spiced with lots of turmeric, c ...umin,
...coriander,
lots of ginger and garlic.
So, a lot going on in this.
...Mark's Indian inspired
cauliflower and paneer pasties
will even come
with spiced pastry,
as he tries to CURRY favour
with Paul and Prue again.
...Last week - Star Baker.
How do you feel today?
...It feels great coming into this week,
but definitely the nerves don't go away.
...That's the sad thing. Star
Baker doesn't guarantee anything.
...No.... Look at them trying to take it away
from you already.... I know, already, yeah.
...You know you have to
prove yourself every time.
...Exactly, yeah. Absolutely.
...Really, really grateful for the smell of
fish this early in the morning. Is that you?
...That's going crazy.
...Getting the
pasty fillings right...
...Oh, that's gorgeous.
.....is just as crucial as
producing flawless pastry...
...You can never have too
much cheese. A bit more?
Just work it all in.
.....incredible flavours..
...Not sure I can fit any
more spices in these.
.....must be complimented
with a perfectly balanced texture.
...I'm happy with that.
...I am making toad
in the hole pasties.
I'm actually calling it
toad-in-the-hole-less pasty
cos I wasn't really sure what was
the toad and what was the hole.
...Lottie's take on this old
favourite will see mashed potato,
onion, sage and fennel gravy,
and Lincolnshire sausage
packed into her pasty.
...Oh,
Lottie. I am not totally convinced by this.
One,
I think it could be really stodgy
or soggy - mash and gravy and...
...I think it sounds delicious. ...It does,
yeah.
...Lottie...... Love toad-in-the-hole.
.....you're always original.... Thank you.
I'll take that.... I have hope,
if not faith.
...Thanks, Prue,
that's all I need.
Do you know what? I'm going to take that with me -
home probably - but still I am going to t ...ake it.
Bakers,
weirdly we are already halfway through.
...Wow! Where does the time go?
...Into a small bum bag
that Paul Hollywood wears.
That's where time goes, kids.
...I'm just worried about time now,
to be honest. It really is disappearing.
...I think this is my third
turn. Can't go too many.
More turns, more lamination.
...If making perfect pastry
isn't time consuming enough,
Pete is planning on sculpting
a whole school of fish pasties.
...I'm saying these pasties are in the shape of
a haddock cos I've got smoked haddock in ...it.
...But it's more shaped
like just generic fish.
...His carefully crafted
pasties will be filled with
the haddock and kedgeree rice
and have a boiled egg centre.
And come complete
with puff pastry scales.
Do you even slightly think
about getting to the final? Yeah.
You want to do the best you can.
...So much. It's
burning you up inside.
It's why I love you because
you're really competitive.
I'd be like that.
Peter's not the only baker hoping to secure
victory by giving pasties a whole new look.
...They're going to be in
the shape of a samosa.
We've been to Goa
a couple of times.
I used to walk quite
a way in the morning
just to get these samosas
that were absolutely beautiful.
...Linda's Goan inspired pasties
will be filled with spiced chicken,
coriander and potato,
with a design flourish that is
not leaving anything to fate.
...I'm going to attempt to
put a little karma symbol...
...Oh, OK,
nice...in Nigella seeds.
Also,
I am hoping that it does stay there.
...If you don't mark this highly,
it's gonna come back at you.... Yeah.
Dave's also taking
inspiration from his travels.
...My filling's based on a
meal that I had out in Thailand.
So,
this is a Thai chilli basil chicken pasty.
...Dave's chicken
and jasmine rice filling
will come with a sweet chilli
dipping sauce on the side.
And his pasties will be
decorated with chilli motifs.
...They're not too hot.
They're bird's eye chillies.
It gives the pasty a kick rather
than an over-powering chilli taste.
...So, now I am on to rolling out my pastry
and cutting out the shapes for my pasties.
...Hopefully that's rested.
...With 45 minutes
of the bake left...
...I'm not being
too precise about it.
.....the bakers must carefully
manage every remaining second.
...I want to get them nice and thin, but
taking me absolute ages to get these right.
...The more time spent
on building their pasties...
...I've got to make sure the filling is completely
cold before I add it into the pastry ...,
...else it's just going to
melt the pastry completely.
.....the less time
they'll get in the oven.
...A fairly generous amount
of filling goes in there.
That is quite tasty,
actually, I must admit.
...I've got to be mindful
not to put too much on,
which is what I normally do,
and then struggle to crimp it.
...Having set up
home in the south-west,
Marc's got a lot riding on his
reinterpretation of the iconic pasty.
...You are from Cornwall, aren't you?
I know. No pressure there, is there?
Technically, though, I'm from up north. So,
that's my get-out clause if they go wrong ....
...No, you are representing Cornwall. ...You won't be
able to go back. ...No, they won't let me bac ...k in.
Marc's paying homage to the Cornish coast with
a monkfish, samphire creamy lemon sauce fill ing
encased in a shortcrust shell,
sealed with traditional pleated crimps.
How many pleats are you doing?
...I don't know.
As many as I can.
...OK.... Should there be a set...? ...There is
a set number, yeah.... Is there really? Yeah.
I'm not going to tell you now.
It's down to the bakers how many
crimps they use to seal their pasties.
...Apparently,
the perfect Cornish pastry's got 20 crimps.
...We don't want none of that on it,
really.
...It's just typically
samosa style.
...My technique is press the
pastry over itself using your fingers,
and hope it looks like a crimp.
...Yeah, it's a bit messy.
This is now melting because it's
been out of the freezer too long.
...That's the last one.
...I'm just giving it an eggwash. It gives a really
nice sort of glaze and shine on the pasti ...es.
I like to imagine that when Paul
has a bath, he has a bath of eggwash.
That's how he gets
that nice bronze look.
...I am adding on some
wee scales quite slapdash.
...I know that they're supposed to be really
nicely neat, but I'd rather they were cooked ....
...Right, going in.
...I'm going to put them in for
35 minutes and check them.
...How long do we have left?
...Bakers,
you've got minutes left. Don't make a bet.
...I won't have time
for highly decorated.
...This is for the
chillies on the top.
...Don't have time so they're
going to go in as they are.
...I was going to put a little... Karma sign on
them...yeah, but I can just get the seeds o ...n.
...At least get some in the oven,
you know?
...Let's not have that speak.... No, that's
true.... You're going to get them all out.
Do you know why?
Because you're Linda -
the inventor of the karma pasty.
...What will be,
will be on that lot.
...I'm going to give them 20 minutes at
200 and then I'll reduce the temperature.
Let's hope they cook.
...Bakers,
you've got 15 minutes.
...Well, 15 minutes left and I
need another 20 minutes, so...
..that doesn't really add up,
does it?
...It is cooked inside,
but you also need the nice brown colour.
...Oh,
God. I'm going to need a miracle.
...I just put another eggwash on
because they aren't very golden.
...I don't know whether to turn them off, or
if that's a bad idea. ...I've got it on 250!
It's like a pizza oven in there.
...How's it going? All right.... Any
leakage? Yeah, all the leakage.
The butter is literally melting out and they're not
crimped properly.... Good sign? No, not ...great.
...This is a Thai sweet
chilli dipping sauce.
Bring that to a boil, come on.
...Still a little bit pale. I
want them to be a bit darker.
...Bakers,
you have five minutes left!
...All right. I'm coming out.
...I think these
bad boys are done.
...Crispy underneath. They
look like fish and they're pasties.
...I'm going to
swap them around.
...Oh, God.
...Bakers, you have one minute.
...OK, I'm coming out.
...Please tell me when
there's 30 seconds.
...I'll take them out at
the very last second.
...My cousin made these
toads for toad-in-the-hole.
...Right, here we come.
...Ugh.... Bakers,
your time is up.
Stop what you're doing, place your
pasties at the end of your work stations.
...Ooh!
...Rustic is good for pasties,
right?
...That's as fine as
you can be with a pasty.
...I'm thinking it's a
shame there's no crimp.
...The bakers' signature
pasties are about to face
Pastry Week's first judging.
...Hey, Prue, Paul.... Hello,
Marc. ...Hey, Marc.... Hello.
...You have the weight of the
whole of Cornwall on your shoulders.
...I certainly have,
which is making me a bit nervous.
...You are lacking on
the number of pleats.
...How many should there be?
...I think it's 20 or 21.
...I was getting close.
...I think you are about seven
or eight short.... Yeah.... Yeah.
The biggest one for me is the colour,
cos they look a bit pale.
Especially this one here,
you haven't brushed it properly.
Flavour is good,
but it's bone dry.
You had cream in
that as well.... Yeah.
...Probably a little
bit more cream.
That would have really given
you more moisture in the mouthful.
It is a little bit too dry for
me. ...OK.... Lovely pastry.
I think if you'd done
it faster and hotter,
you might have kept a
little more of the colour.
...OK.
...The overall look of this one
is fantastic. It is like a flatfish.
It looks great.
...I was a bit worried
it would be stodgy,
but, in fact,
it's certainly not.
If anything, it's a bit dry.
...There's a nice
kick of flavour there,
but, unfortunately,
you've got rice sitting on a pastry,
which is very good, but,
essentially, quite dry.
I think they are
a little bit messy.
You've lost the definition
in the pleats across the top.
But I like the colour of
them. ...I think it's very witty.
...Very flaky, which is good.
WHISPERS:... Nice.
...They taste amazing.
The mash works really well.
...Do you remember
I said it won't work?
I was wrong. ...It is very,
very good.
It doesn't look good,
but the textures,
the flavours are all spot
on. They taste amazing.
...Yeah, can you book me one for lunch?
...Yeah, I'll book you one, no worries.
...I'm serious.... Yeah,
yeah. ...I want one. That one.... Yeah.
...They are very nice indeed.
They're nicely glazed,
they are well baked,
they are the right colour
and there are the little
chillies on top.... Yes.
...They are very
impressive.... Thank you.
...I think your flavour is OK.
I think it's a little bit dry,
though,
I think you put too
much rice in there.... OK.
...Because the rice is going to dry
everything out, soak everything in.
You have lost the flavour of the chicken,
but, otherwise,
I mean, the pastry is good.
It's all right to eat, it just doesn't,
you know, wow me.
...OK, that's fair enough.... Can I
just taste it with your sauce? Yes, yes.
...Do you know,
that would have made a huge difference?
Because it has that sweetness
and the chilli and a little bit of kick.
Thank you.
Do you know, that is really
what a pasty should look like.
It is full, the pastry looks beautiful,
soft and tender,
but firm enough to,
if not hurl over a hedge,
at least hold in your
hand. ...It tastes beautiful.
The spices in there, the chilli in
there was just the right amount.
It's got a nice kick of heat in
there. The textures are spot on.
It's gorgeous. Very good.
...Heaven.... You do realise a
handshake from me is valueless?
...It's a lot of value
to me.... Yeah.
There you are, Mark.... Phew!
It was all right.... You were a
bit worried, weren't you? I was.
...Well done.
...Another couple of minutes, perhaps,
in the oven? I was running behind.
...So you were rushing...? Yeah.
...Nice and full.... That's beautiful.
The lamb is cooked beautifully.
...Thank you.... The flavours,
the spices...
...Just the right
amount of veg to meat.
It's beautiful.
...That is a lovely pasty.
Because you've got a good
pastry on the outside, quite buttery.
...It's really delicious.... Thank
you. ...Thank you very much indeed.
...Well done,
Hermine.... Thank you.
...Sorry they didn't like it.
...Well, you did read the stuff about
we were going to want them crimped?
...Oh.... Did you miss that? ...I
missed that on the brief. Sorry.
...OK, so we have a samosa,
essentially.... Yes.
...I'd like the
colour of them...
They are a little bit white in
places and broken up slightly,
a bit longer in the oven,
perhaps? ...Yes, absolutely.
...Your stencilling didn't work.... No.
...You know what? It looks very nice.
...The flavours are fantastic.
I think you've got the idea
of the samosa right in there.
I'd like to have seen the
crimping which you didn't do,
but what I do like is the
combination of the butteriness
with the samosa filling.
...A delicious lunch.
...Well done.... Thank you.
...Nice colour. You've got a
beautiful sort of golden brown colour.
You have got a little bit
of crimping on the edge.
A little bit irregular in size.
...I like the fact
they're nice and fat.
There is going to be a good lot of
filling in there.... Nice flaky pastry.
The filling in there, as well,
going right to the sides.
...Heaven. I love that.
It's flaky,
the pastry is holding together,
its moist in the middle but
not wet. I could gobble it up.
...Thank you.... I think you've got
the perfect blend there of ingredients.
The texture and flavour are spot on... Oh,
thank you... Well done... Well done.
...Thank you. Thanks.
...Well done,
Laura.... I'll take that.
Oh, my God, that was amazing.
To impress Paul with the
pastry and Prue with the filling,
like, double whammy.
...They liked it. What more?
...I knew the flavours were going
to be good. I could smell them.
...I am worried about the
Technical because, with pastry,
they can do literally anything.
If I could just not be
bottom in Technical again,
that would be great.
...As usual,
the bakers can practise their signatures.
But what they will
bake in the Technical
is only now about
to be revealed.
...Bakers,
it's now time for your Technical Challenge,
which, today,
has been set by Prue.
Prue,
thanks for joining us in the tent.
Do you have any words of advice?
...This is all about refinement,
so the inside must be
as perfect as the outside.
...As ever, this technical
challenge will be judged blind,
so could you two
please leave the tent?
We will see you later on.
Prue would like you
to make three raspberry
and three salted
caramel eclairs.
...Prue is looking for precision,
perfect piping,
baked until golden brown. You
have two hours and 15 minutes.
...On your marks......
Get set.... Bake.
...There is a lot of
steps in this recipe.
I just grabbed out
all the saucepans.
...I've not made eclairs before.
I have made choux before,
but not eclairs.
...Eclairs themselves will be easy,
but it's not just eclairs,
there's a lot going on.
...I'm not sure about this one.
...Prue,
eclairs is the Technical Challenge.
Personally,
I think it's a good one.
...Most people think
eclairs are very easy.
But if you want really high-end,
elegant, special ones,
then you have to
do a lot of work.
...There is one choux
pastry for all of these.
...Well, I should think
they've all made choux pastry,
they should all be
able to make it well.
Then you have to make
creme pat to fill them all with.
Half of that creme pat needs to
be flavoured with salted caramel,
and the other half,
seedless raspberry puree.
...The little kick from the salted
caramel blended with the sweetness
of the raspberry,
you've got a nice balance between the two.
You have set them a very
difficult Technical Challenge.
...We are halfway through.
The bakers that are
left are really good.
...You can talk,
I'm eating, go on...
...So it says......
Make the choux.
...So just make the choux.
...Put the sugar, the milk,
the water and the butter into a pan
and heat it over a low heat.
...Chuck the flour in.
...Mix, mix, mix, mix,
mix, so it forms a paste.
...It's just not thick enough.
It's just not what
I expected at all.
Oh,
it's a long time since I made it,
so I'm not 100% sure about this.
...Do all right on the eclairs.
...I'm all right on eclairs,
but there's so many steps in this.
...It's a lot of reading, that,
isn't it? She writes books.
There's quite a racy scene
between two farm hands there.
...Yes, bit by bit until you
get the right consistency.
...I think it's meant to,
like, stick to the spoon,
like,
not want to come off from it very well.
...It has to be
dropping consistency.
You are looking for a
V-shape off a spatula or spoon.
Reluctant to drop.... That's what you
want. There you go, there is your V.
...I'm going to pipe the
choux out onto the baking tray.
...I need to pipe carefully.
...I'm happy with them.
Yeah, they'll do,
they'll do. ...These are going in the oven.
...It does not give us any instructions
on how long to bake these for.
I'm going to start off with 15,
see how they're going,
and then just
take it from there.
...No, I'm not certain that's right.
I'm not certain that's right at all.
I'm making my creme pat.
Creme patissiere is just custard.
It's just a posh
word for custard.
...Don't want it to be lumpy,
so I'll make sure that I keep
stirring it whilst it's heating up.
...Absolutely no
idea what I'm doing.
Just finding new ways
to make scrambled egg.
...It's a bit grainier
than I'd like it to be.
...It's too wet. There's too many
elements that can go wrong on this.
...Are you left-handed?
...I am left-handed.
...You know a left-handed
person has never won the Bake Off.
...Good boost of confidence.
...You know someone who
has ever worn a yellow T-shirt
has never won the Bake Off.
...Oh, no!
...They are not rising at all.
I would have expected to
see some movement in it.
They are looking a bit oily.
...I think they are cooked,
you know.
...Oh, dear, they have, like,
risen quite a lot, haven't they?
...They are looking nice
and crisp on the outside.
...They could
be slightly fatter.
I don't know how
I'm going to fill them.
...They're not lovely golden
brown. They'll have to do.
...They've kind of
already deflated a little bit.
...No, that's not happening.
Right, let's have another think.
Bakers, you have roughly one hour,
seven minutes and 30 seconds left.
...You are halfway through....
You can put it like that if you want.
...I'm going to do the choux again.
Hopefully, I've got time to bake it.
...Make the caramel
with 100g of sugar.
...In we go.
...Every time I make caramel in this tent,
it goes wrong.
I'm going to keep
it on a low heat
and then I'm just not
going to touch it ever.
...Got to keep my
eye on that caramel.
This is taking forever.
...Doesn't look right, does it?
Is it harder to cook
on television? ...Yeah.
...Would you go on any other shows?
Would you go on Naked Attraction?
I wouldn't go on
Naked Attraction
because my body
is my own business.
...I'm really not sure what
to do if that doesn't work.
I'm just going to try and give her
the elements as much as I can.
I'm going to mash them up a bit.
...Make a seedless
raspberry puree.
I'm leaving the seeds in there
and once it's pureed down,
I'll sieve it,
get rid of the seeds.
...Just a little bit thin. I
don't know if that will set.
...So now,
I'm making the salted caramel sauce.
This is going to be
mixed with the creme pat
to make a nice salted
caramel custard.
...It says one teaspoon
of salt. ...It's quite dark.
But I just need to
get it chilled now
so I can fold it
into the creme pat.
...I'm just really baffled.
Mine don't look like they're
going to do anything different.
I don't know why I'm
making all the additional bits
if I've got nothing
to put them in.
...Do you want me to...
..go to the supermarket
and buy some eclairs?
...I think you'd better.
Just split my creme pat into two
and now I'm folding it
through the raspberry
and the salted caramel.
I think I am kind of feeling in my
comfort zone right now. It's good.
...It looks beautiful indeed.
...Yeah,
it's a little bit lumpy.
I think it'll be OK.
...I know I'm going to
be really out of time,
but I'm going to
have one more go.
I'm going to re-make the choux.
...Bakers,
you have half an hour left.
...Now what? Fill three of the
eclairs with raspberry filling.
...I'm doing this
so cack-handedly.
...I thought,
rather than doing creme patissiere,
I'll make a raspberry yoghurt
to go inside. So here it goes.
...It's just all totally
dripping out of it.
I'm not really sure
why that's happened.
I just think my puree
wasn't thick enough
when I added it
to the creme pat.
...The choux are collapsed,
so it's really difficult
to get the stuff in.
...We'll just have to go with it,
I think, today.
...It tastes all right. It looks split,
though.
Oh, my God!
...The creme pat is too wet.
...Terrible. My
creme pat is just flat.
...The salted caramel icing is
going to be piped over the top.
...That's not my finest work.
...Ooh!
Nearly didn't have those, then.
Third time lucky.
...Bakers,
you have five minutes left.
...Crikey!
...I'm really not sure
what to do with them.
...Winging it!
...This is not my usual
highly decorated standard.
...Yes,
there's a lot going on at once.
...Just going to...
...I'm so stressed.
...They can have a dip of the
creme patissiere and the coulis.
You know? I've done what I can.
...This is horrendous!
...Bakers, your time is up.
...Disappointed.
...Please, bring your eclairs
down to the front and place them
behind your photographs.
...Look at this, at least it gets mine
out of the way first.... Well done.
...Prue and Paul are
looking for six elegant eclairs.
Three filled with a
salted caramel creme pat
and three with a
raspberry creme pat.
OK,
shall we start with this one?
The toppings are sort
of there or thereabouts.
...And they are more
or less the right colour.
...Yeah.... OK,
let's see what the creme pat's like.
Oh, this one is empty.
And that one is runny.
It's completely liquid.
Mm. Nice flavour.
...The flavours are right,
but it's too thick and the
consistency on the eclair
and the creme pat is not right.
Moving on to number
two. These look quite neat.
All the same size. ...This
icing has set all right.
...Look at that. It's split.
The raspberry flavour is there,
but the consistency is all wrong inside.
What? Those weren't finished.
...Oh,
it's a dip one. Oh, I see.
I get it. I see.
There is no rise in that.
It obviously hasn't
got any flour in it.
...I can't understand that.
...That's terrible.
All right. Moving on.
...These are rather fat.
...But having said that,
they look like eclairs.
The raspberry one actually tastes
OK. And the eclair is baked well.
...Yes, not bad effort.
...Moving on.... A bit skinny....
Yeah. I mean, they look neat enough.
...The pastry is just not baked
enough. ...The flavours of both are OK.
It's the textures
that are wrong.
...This is an original
take on the icing.
Looks like a giant caterpillar.
...Needed longer in the oven.
...There's a lot
wrong with this eclair.
The creme pat is scrambled,
the pastry is really soft
and under baked.
OK, I'm cheering up a little here
because these are more or less OK.
That's empty. That's
empty. This one's got some...
...The caramel in there is OK.
...Oh, it is, but there's very
little creme pat in the middle.
...There's nothing in there.
Moving on to the last one. Now,
these are all the same. Quite neat.
The right consistency
with the creme pat.
Good flavour as well.... Mm.
...Not bad at all.... No.... Very good.
The judges will now rank
the eclairs from worst to best.
In eighth spot, comes as no surprise,
this one, whose is this?
Linda?
A few issues with the choux,
your caramel
should go on the top
and there's no creme pat inside.
...In seventh place,
we have this one.
...Mine.... They're a bit long and
thin and a bit under-baked.... Yeah.
...Laura takes sixth. Dave
is fifth. And Lottie gets fourth.
...In third place,
we had this one. Mark.
You were redeemed by the fact
that the pastry was well-cooked
and that they tasted delicious,
but they were really messy.
...In second spot,
we have this one.
These are pretty good. They could
just have been a little bit thinner.
They're just a
little bit too fat.
...Which means,
the winner is this one.
Peter, they were delicious.
My only quarrel was they
were probably a little bit fat,
but I thought they were lovely.
We both thought they
were lovely. Well done.
...APPLAUSE
...That is the first time
I've won the Technical,
so tick it off the bucket list,
the Bake Off bucket list.
...Really happy. Earned it well.
...It wasn't my finest hour,
that one.
...Two hours trying to make choux pastry,
disgusting.
But tomorrow is another day.
...There's just
one challenge left
before Paul and Prue
decide who will be Star Baker
and who will be
leaving the tent today.
...Bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper challenge.
Paul and Prue would
like you each to make
a caged tart.
...An exquisite, sweet tart
contained within an
intricately-latticed pastry cage.
...You can work with
any type of pastry you like,
but it must be self-supporting
and highly decorative.
And remember,
this is your Showstopper,
so it needs to look
and taste superb!
...Matthew,
did you know the caged tart
was actually invented
by actor Nicolas Cage?
...Yes, Noel. I did know that.
Did you know that Nicolas Cage
is a big fan of this show? Really?
...Yes,
he watches this and Homes Under The Hammer.
...You have three hours,
45 minutes to complete your caged tarts.
...On your
marks...... Get set...
...Bake!
...HE SIGHS
...The sun is shining, yeah.
And I'm smiling.
...LINDA CHUCKLES
...I am at the moment.
Till we're dishing up.
...This is a really
tough challenge.
You know,
anyone can bake a tart,
but making a caged tart...
...The biggest issue is the cage,
no doubt.
I've never managed to make
this caged tart in its entirety.
...Why would you make a
caged tart? ...It's bonkers.
It looks beautiful.
You're supposed to showcase it,
not cage it.
...PRUE:... We've
gone all out here.
We want the most
elegant latticed cage
made of pastry.
...The cage can't be too solid
that you can't see the tart
and it's gotta be
structurally sound,
so it's actually quite
a difficult challenge.
...This has to be a
really special tart.
It has to be luscious.
The kind of tart that you really
want to eat a huge amount of,
but you shouldn't,
because it's very rich.
...What I'm looking for is a very thin,
crispy base.
Lots of filling,
punching with flavour
and a beautifully-decorated top.
...They're good bakers.
I have every confidence.
...First hour really is all about
me getting my doughs ready.
...The bakers are free to use
whatever pastry they choose...
...I'm making a sweet
pastry for the tart itself
and then I'm doing a
different pastry for the cage.
.....but must keep in mind each
dough has a different job to do.
...This is the sweet crust
pastry for the tart case.
...The tart must be
crisp and delicious...
...I'm just making my
hazelnut pastry now.
.....while the cage must
be strong and sturdy.
...I'm gonna have to say
it's a French sweet pastry,
because I can't pronounce...
...This is my pate
sucree tart base.
It's a crumbly pastry,
but it's not so crumbly
that I can't work with it.
...I'm making three
different types of pastry.
It is, after all, Pastry Week.
...Lottie's bake will be housed in an
ambitious choux pastry pyramid cage.
Unusually for a tart,
it will have pastry layers with pureed,
caramelised and raw apple
sandwiched in between.
...I question whether it
would be a tart without sides.
...I did look up the
definition of the word tart.
It's from an old French
word that means flat pastry.
...PRUE:... Right.
...Are you confident?
...I'm confident
in all but the cage.
...But there's more than one
pyramid under construction today.
...The cage is
inspired by the Louvre.
I don't know if it's
Showstopper incredible,
but we'll wait and see.
...Dave's aiming to serve a
set mango and lime filling,
on a cocoa and
sweet pastry base,
presented in a Parisian
museum-inspired cage.
...Interesting flavours. I like
the idea of mango and lime.
...You're gonna stick it
together with caramel?
...Yeah, it's stuck together with
caramel.... That's very difficult.
...Very difficult to glue it together
with caramel.... Well, good luck.
...This is my tart case.
I'm just trying to not
overstretch it. ...SHE CHUCKLES
...I'm pricking the
base of the tart.
Erm...... HE LAUGHS
...That's gonna allow
any steam to escape
and stop it from getting
all bumpy and uneven,
and then this pastry's
gonna blind bake.... In it goes.
...That's going in.
...That's going in now,
this one.
...This is the cage pastry.
...Can I just say,
I love it when you beat the butter up.
Are you thinking it's Paul?
...I couldn't possibly say.
...Hi, Laura.... Hello! ...Hi,
Laura.... Hello!
...Laura,
tell us all about your caged tart.
...I'm doing a Key lime
pie inspired tart.... Ooh!
...I'm going with a bit
of a botanical theme,
so I'll hopefully show you I
can do delicate and fine today.
...Laura's limey filling will
sit on a crunchy ginger pastry,
accented with Italian meringue.
It'll be caged in a
domed puff pastry lattice,
adorned with pastry snails
and elegant butterflies.
...This one's for my dad.
He absolutely loves this.
He devours it every time I
make it for family gatherings.
...Key lime pie's one of my
favourite things.... Is it? I love it.
...You know,
you're on a winner there.
...Now,
I'm gonna make the pastry for my cage.
I certainly did not make a
pastry cage before this challenge.
...A true test of
pastry prowess,
the bakers must
hit the sweet spot
with dough strong
enough not to collapse,
but tender enough for eating.
...I'm literally doing
the exact same again.
My cage sable. Pate sable.
Yeah, cocoa pate sable.
...This choux isn't very robust. Yeah,
it's a hell of a risk.
I've gone for that,
because if I can nail it, it looks good.
...It's the same pastry
recipe as the pastry case.
I've adapted the recipe
so that it doesn't fall apart
when it's moulded.
...Rough puff isn't probably something
you would use to build a cage in.
It's quite a risky one.
I just really hope it works.
...What's the cage
about? ...The cage is weird.
I'd never seen a caged tart
before. ...I don't know if I have.
...No, but they do look quite cool when they
turn out well. ...I'll take your word for it.
...Peter's tart will have
a hazelnut pastry base,
a baked lemon filling
and blackberry curd
and it will shelter under
a domed shortcrust cage,
decorated with edible flowers.
...I love a lemon tart.
It's... I think it's
my favourite.
I like this one a lot.
...But he's not the only baker
tweaking the classic tarte au citron.
...I'm making a lemon tart,
so hopefully I will manage that.
...Hermine's tangy
lemon and lime filling
will be topped with
sweet Italian meringue.
She'll box her bake in
with an ornate pastry cage.
...You had such a great day
yesterday. Can you do it again?
...I am hoping, cos I kept saying,
"Bread Week wasn't mine.
"Biscuit Week wasn't mine."
And I feel Pastry Week
is the area where I excel.
...Good.... More of the same,
please.
...I'm gonna start making
the panels to make the cage.
...These are my stencils that
I'm gonna pipe my choux onto
and then cook it
and then assemble it.
Sounds easy, doesn't it?
No.
...I've rolled out my rough puff
and I'm just using
some circle cutters
and then I'll pull
that over the mould.
...This is just
a lattice cutter.
...It cuts out all
the lattices for you.
...These are my strands
to make the cage.
Put them in the oven and then they
come off the bowl. That's the plan.
...There's no particular
pattern that I'm going for here.
It's just kind of make some nice,
wavy lines, hope it looks good
and make sure that enough of them cross
over, so it gives it a bit of structure.
...When it goes in the oven,
hopefully it will gel together.
...I'm cutting out rhomboid shapes
in it now, inspired by the Louvre.
...It is a pyramid. This is me
trying to be creative, all right?
...Is that a cage
or is that a helmet?
Who in this room would you
put in your cage, if you could?
...Oh, I think, like, a really little
mini Peter would be quite cute.
...Yeah.
Oi, Peter!
Laura wants to
put you in a cage.
...Poor kid. He looks terrified.
...What would you do with him if
he was in a cage? Feed him cheese.
...Noel, after this time call,
would you like to play table tennis?
...Yeah! Bakers,
you're halfway through.
...Hm, halfway to paradise.
I'm gonna get my
tart case out now.
...Ooh.
Naughty.
...Yeah,
I'm happy with the way they look.
...It's cracked a little bit,
but it's gonna have a filling in it,
so that'll be hidden.... A little
bit darker than I wanted in parts,
but I'll be trimming all that off.
...It's fine, but it's not phenomenal.
...With their cages moulded,
cut out or piped,
it's now the bakers can
get them in the oven.
...I'll give it 25 minutes,
then check it.
...This is going
in for 20 minutes.
Two at a time.
...Fingers crossed.
...Good luck,
my beautiful little helmet!
...Please! Pray that this works.
Fingers crossed.
...How's it going?
...It's going all right.
It's a tough one,
this one.... Why?
...It's just a lot to do.
A lot to think about.
A lot can go wrong. ...What
has gone wrong so far?
...Nothing's gone wrong so far.
...Well, then,
you just lied to me.
...All being well,
Mark will put together a pear and sage tart
with layers of pear jam,
a pear and sage mousse
that will sit inside a rough
puff pastry bottle cage,
resting on shortbread
biscuit sand.
...Goodness,
this is an ambitious business.
...I love the idea of the sage.
...I'm confident that it's gonna work.
I have to be positive. ...Thank you,
Mark.... Fingers crossed.
Thank you very much.... You've
got them excited about the flavours.
...It just has to look good now as
well.... It will. Good luck.... Thank you.
...OK, what now?
...While the pastry cage
demonstrates design,
the filling for their tart is a
chance for the bakers to showcase
a flair for flavour.
...This is the
chocolate cremeux.
It's just like a really
thick chocolate cream.
...It's toffee popcorn
creme diplomate.
It tastes like
popcorn at a push.
...Yesterday was yesterday and
yesterday was a different creme pat.
...I'm just making
the gypsy tart.
It's actually just sugar
and evaporated milk.
It's been a favourite of
mine when I was at school.
That's why I'm making it.
...Linda's gypsy tart
has a sweet pastry base,
topped with a coffee and
brandy-soaked sponge.
It will nestle in a colourful
rosewater-flavoured pastry dome.
...Word on the street is
you're doing a gypsy tart.
...I'm doing a gypsy tart,
yes.... What?
Cos when I was at primary school,
we used to have gypsy tart
and it was my
favourite...... Yeah.
.....and I've never
seen it since.... Yeah.
...And you're making
it today? Yeah.
I mean,
very simple ingredients. ...Come on.
I don't care how simple it
is. Come on! Come on, yes.
Come on! Good
luck.... Thank you.
...After a tough
time in the technical,
Marc's also banking
on a much-loved bake.
...My favourite pudding
in the whole wide world
is a blackberry and apple pie.
So, this is kind of like a
posh apple and blackberry pie.
...Marc's upmarket tart will
have a sable Breton base,
blackberry jam,
caramelised apples
and a chocolate cremeux.
His full puff pastry cage will be
decorated with shortcrust flowers
and vine leaves.
...If it turns out how I want it,
I'll be really pleased.
...I am sweating today.
There's just a lot to do. I
feel... I'm feeling behind already.
How long do we have left?
...Bakers...... You
have one hour left.
...I thought we were good in that. ...Yeah,
I think it worked very well.
...I'm gonna get
my cage out now.
...It is very fragile.
...It's a nice
golden-brown colour.
...All going well.
...Looks quite good.
...I was hoping they'd
glue together a bit more.
...Let these cool down,
cos they're too
delicate at the moment.
...I'm gonna shove it
straight in the freezer
to try and cool it down.
...As cages cool,
the blind-baked tarts can be
moved on to the next stage.
...Put it in the oven for 15 minutes.
Then we'll have a lemon tart.
...While some fillings are baked,
others must be cooled to firm up.
...I'm putting the jam in and then
build up the cremeux from that
and chill for 15 minutes.
...With tarts left to set,
the bakers can crack on,
preparing finishing touches.
...At last, some pear action,
hey? I'm using conference pears.
You need to stop making
me say that word in my accent.
...NORTHERN IRISH
ACCENT:... Pear.
...I'm gonna put
my macaroons in.
...This is a little
lacy template
that I'm gonna slide
onto the top of the tart.
You know like you get a
doily and it's all da-de-da!
...This is my caramel and then
we're gonna add the apples.
And that'll be one of my
layers. Let's just hope that works.
...Look at this little fruit selection.
...A cute lunch for a rabbit.
...# I'm preparing
lunch for a rabbit. #
You look quite calm today.
# Star Baker is looming
in the distance. #
And you're making
lunch for a rabbit.
...Come on, man.
...Hello, lattice head.
Are you ready for
a time call? ...Yeah.
...Bakers,
you have half an hour left.
...What? Is that real? Half
an hour? It's gonna be tight.
...Is this is the lockdown
look? That's right, kids.
If you can't get out
there on the high street,
then pastry is your answer.
...Yeah, it's done.
...Oh, look at that,
though. Yeah.
It's a good set.
...Wonderful...SHE CHUCKLES
...Very happy.
...This is the cage.
Oh, God. This is terrifying.
...The cage is pretty delicate,
so it's all about
getting it off.
This is what this entire
bake hinges on right now.
It's a little scary.
...Oh,
I'm panicking now. I'm rushing.
...If it works, I'm laughing.
...This is the tricky bit,
cos I need to glue all the sides.
I would say they're brittle.
...Oh!
...Let's see if this comes off,
shall we?
...I've never felt so stressed.
...This is isomalt.
It's like sugar,
but more predictable.
...Glue the hell
out of that lot.
...I'm trying to stay nice and
calm. ...I don't know what to do.
It's just breaking as
I'm trying to get it off.
...I don't think I'm going
to get it off in one piece.
...It will look messy.
...Is that stuck?
...MARK SIGHS
...Damn it.
...Oh, I'm so pleased.
...Oh! Oh!
...Eurgh!
...It's still too hot.
...Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
...This is now assembly, yeah.
Here we go.
...It's gonna be like a flower
piece on the top of the tart.
...That is the Italian meringue.
...The meringue's gonna go
around the outside of the tart.
Then the fruits just
sit pretty in the middle.
...This is my
blackberry curd on top.
Tastes good. Perfect.
...It's just a case of
laying the apples on,
arranging the
blackberries and then run.
...This is not the way
I want to finish this off,
but it's gonna have to do.
...Not quite what it should be.
...It might be a bit sticky.
...I'm happy with the tart.
Hopefully I can cage it.
...Just feel the
tension in the room!
...It's broken now.
...Bakers,
you have one minute left.
...I don't know what to
do. It just all collapsed.
...I'll see if I can get it off.
I've got about five seconds.
...Eurgh!
...OK, bakers. Your time is up.
I just wanted to get a
little bit of colour on it.
...It better taste good.
...HE SIGHS... I will take that.
...Oh, that was touch and go,
I'll be honest.
...I don't think I've been as
proud of anything in my entire life
as I am of that.
...Hey-ho.
It's a shame, isn't it?
...NOEL:... It's judgment time for
the bakers' cage tart Showstoppers.
Dave, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
...I think it looks great.
I do like the look you've managed
to achieve with the mango.
...I think it's wonderful.
All it has to do now is taste
great. ...Fingers crossed.
...It's nice and neat.
...The flavour is absolutely
lovely. Love the mango.
...The base is just
about the right thickness.
It marries up beautifully
with the mango.
I think you've done a great job,
because you've given an impact
to the top of the tart, as well.
...The overall look
is so harmonious.
...Very good job.... Well done.
...Cheers,
thank you.... Really good.
...It looks highly effective.
The colour looks very,
very good.
I like the way the tart looks.
...Yeah.... Looks great.
...Lovely and rich,
the chocolate.
I do have a problem
with the base.
It's a bit big for the
chocolate. ...Yeah.
...But I think your
decoration is very beautiful.
...I'd liked to have
seen this chocolate
to the edge of a very
rich chocolate pastry
which was really thin.
That would've
been spot-on.... OK.
...Cos that base looks
awkward.... Yeah.
...So it doesn't
belong...... Yeah.
.....with that delicate chocolate
in the middle.... OK, sure.
...I think it looks beautiful.
I think it's a really
clever design,
and I think you've
managed to get it to work...
..until Paul
Hollywood wrecked it.
...NOEL GROANS, LAUGHTER
NOEL:... Thunder fingers.
...However, that shows that
the pastry will be delicious.
...The flavour's lovely.
...Mm.... But you could have gone a
little bit thinner with that base.... OK.
...But I have to say,
the pastry is beautiful.
...It is, really good.
...However,
this is a really big, hefty,
Paul Hollywood...... SHE GRUNTS
.....cage, with a delicate,
tiny, feminine middle.
...It's a Prue Leith tart...
...And a Paul Hollywood cage. .....with
a Paul Hollywood base. LAUGHTER
Overall, though, I think all your
flavours are absolutely spot-on.
...I'm very impressed
with your cage.
...Thank you.... I
think it looks lovely.
...I think it's
highly impressive.
The tart underneath looks very,
very nice.
...Mm.
I love...
..the Key lime flavour.
...The lime,
you can feel it at the back of your...
...Mm...cheeks. It's like, oof.
And I like that from lime.
That's how a lime should taste. You know,
give you a nice kick.
I think your
decoration's beautiful.
Overall, I think your taste's amazing,
looks good.
...Excellent.
...I think you've
excelled yourself. ...Mm.
You really have.
...Wow, thank you. That
means a lot to me. Thank you.
...What happened to the cage?
...It usually lifts up,
but today it stayed on the bowl.
...Yeah, I love the gypsy colours.
...That's right, yeah.... Are great.
OK, let's taste it.
Mm.
I love the flavour.
...It's a bit thick,
that gypsy tart, actually.
It could have been
a little bit thinner.
Um... I quite like the flavour,
it's very traditional.
It's quite frustrating that
you don't see the full impact.
The way it looks
doesn't look good.
...Well, I have to say,
your cage is sensational.
Really beautiful.
...The artistry in
there is exceptional.
The tart itself...
..I question whether it
would be a tart without sides.
...Very squidgy.
...Very.
...Mm.
That tastes
absolutely beautiful.
But it does look a right mess.
...All the independent flavours are very,
very good.
All the textures are good.
What you've made is very good,
but "Is it the brief?" is my
question. PRUE CHUCKLES
...I like the rather random
way you've done the cage.
I think it's really beautiful.
...It's quite solid, it almost looks
like it's made of bread.
...I'm just happy it's held up.
...LAUGHTER
Lovely and tart.
...Mm.... Mm.
That's delicious. Puts a smile on
your face, doesn't it? Very nice.
...I think partly because the back
of your cheeks are going...
LAUGHTER
..and so it sort of forces a smile.
It's called a happy tart, that one.
That's lovely.
...So, the cage didn't work.
...It's not a good one.
Not compared with what
you were achieving recently.
That's not...... Yeah.
.....Mark.... Mm.
...Your piping's all irregular,
as well.
The poached pears
don't look appetising.
...It's delicious. It's unusual,
but I really like it.
...The pastry's far too thick.
I think you missed something
on this one.... Mm.
...At a core level, not just at the
fact that you never got a chance
to finish it with a cage.
...Didn't go well, did it?
I'm obviously in a very
precarious position now.
...Pastry Week!
It was supposed to be my week.
Hey-ho. Fair comments.
...I think that's probably the nicest
bit of feedback that I've got,
that line of it being a happy tart.
...Paul said my pastry was amazing.
"Amazing."
I mean, what more...
...That's definitely the best
feedback that I've had yet.
I got a bit choked, actually.
I've... I'm absolutely made up.
...I thought they did quite well
after the eclairs.
...The cages were astonishing,
except for Mark L.
...And Linda's.... And Linda's.
I think,
in spite of her exploding cage,
Hermine must be in line
for Star Baker.
...I thought the flavours of her lemon
tarte au citron was fantastic.
...You did quite like Dave's.
...I thought his cage was incredible.
...What about Peter?
Cos you liked his, as well.
...I did like his.
...And he came first in Technical.
Is he not in line for Star Baker?
...He struggled in his Signature
quite badly.... Right.
...But I think Laura's Showstopper
was amazing.
...Laura's had a good week, hasn't she?
...She's really come up.
...So, who is in danger of going home?
...Mark L. His cage fell apart.
He could be in a little bit
of trouble. And Marc E.
He struggled in the Technical
and he struggled in the Signature.
I think Linda's in trouble.
She struggled across
the first two challenges.
She didn't finish her cage.
...Close, then.... It is.
It's painfully close.
...Well done, bakers.
You must be exhausted.
I'm sure you want to know
who Star Baker is,
so I'll tell you.
Star Baker this week is...
..Laura.
...APPLAUSE... Well done!
...Congratulations, Laura.... Bloody hell.
...That leaves me with the rotten job
of announcing the person
that is leaving us this week.
It does get harder every week,
cos there's less of you
and we get to know you more.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
..Linda. I'm sorry.
...No, that's good.
I can't really be sad.
I've been like a child
at Disneyland, really.
Well done, you.... I'm so sorry.
...It's been amazing.
One of the highlights of my life.
...How dare they! Thank you so much.
...You've been brilliant.
...She is a very good baker,
but she had a terrible week.
...I know I can bake.
I just haven't done enough.
I am so proud of myself, yeah.
I am.
...Well done, Laura.... Oh, thank you.
...You did well there.... Thank you.
I'm still a bit in shock.
I think I'm a bit, like,
did that actually just happen?
...When it came to the Showstopper,
I thought Laura
smashed it out the park.
A well-deserved Star Baker.
...I'm just gonna try and get through
for as long as I can.
Hashtag winging it.
...I'm looking forward to next week.
Japanese Week.
...Yeah, one more.
Let's do one more week.
...It's getting tougher and tougher now
and I cannot mess up
like that again.
Yeah, I'm gonna be better
next week.
...Next time...
...The adrenaline has kicked in.
.....it's a Bake Off first,
with Japanese Week.
...I just like it being a bit
different.... Yeah.... Cakes are boring.
...Who will run out of steam
in the Signature? Whoa.... Good God.
...The bakers are spread thin and
turned over in a tense technical...
...Flip, go on! Yes!
...The winner right here.
..and a spectacularly sweet
Showstopper...
...Cute...that will leave one
of the bakers with a sour taste.
...It's tearing a bit, isn't it?
Oh, God.... BLEEP... mess.
...I don't know why you're so upset.
I think that looks pretty neat.
>>>>oakislandtk
www.opensubtitles.org